Transcriber: Metin Akın
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Öncelikle 19 Mayıs Atatürk'ü Anma
Gençlik ve Spor Bayramımız kutlu olsun
Erdemlerimizin...
İyi en baştan alkışı aldım ben
artık sorun yok.
Erdemlerimizi ve değerlerimizi
unutmadığımız
nice 19 Mayıs’lara arkadaşlar.
Konuşmama başlamadan önce
şunu belirtmek istiyorum.
Siz bu koltuklarda oturduğunuzda
birçoğunuz şunu düşünüyor olabilirsiniz:
"Ben acaba bir gün TEDx’e çıkacak mıyım?"
Ya da arkadaşlarınızla bunun
sohbetini yapıyor olabilirsiniz.
"Ya biz acaba çıkacak mıyız TEDx'e?"
Emin olun; gerçekten,
içten istediğiniz zaman
ve ona çalıştığınız zaman
bir gün burada olacaksınız.
Size tecrübeden söyleyebilirim.
Üç ay önce hiçbir fikriniz yokken, üç ay
sonra kendinizi bir TEDx sahnesinde
bulabilirsiniz. Yeter ki isteyin.
Çok tanınan bir sima olmadığım
için öncelikle kısaca
kendimden bahsetmek istiyorum.
Bunlar beni nitelendiren şeyler.
AJ isimli bir Avrupa öğrenciler forumunda
uzun süreler aktif olarak çalıştım.
Girişimcilik Hikâyeleri isimli
bir eğitim firmam var.
Yüksek lisansımı Belçika'da yaptım.
Girişimcilik Hikâyeleri isimli
bir kitabım var.
Ama bugün burada olmamın sebebi
ben bir gezginim.
30 yaşında 60 ülkeye gitmiş bir gezginim.
Bu benim blogum,
biraz ilham almanız dileğiyle.
Bize İngilizce öğrettiklerinde
ilk öğretilen kült kelimelerden
cümlelerden biri nedir arkadaşlar?
What is this? diye sorarlar.
Biz ne deriz?
This is a pencil deriz.
Yaklaşık 10 sene önce Almanya'da
bir gençlik değişimine gittiğimizde
4 ülkenin farklı grubundan Hollanda grubu
Almanya grubu, Bulgarlar ve biz
Euro-Islam isimli bir projeye gittik.
Farklı dinlerin bir arada olmasıyla ilgili
çok entellektüel sohbetlerin olduğu
ve güzel aktivitelerin olduğu
bir projeye gittik.
Bizim grupta Murat
diye bir arkadaşımız vardı.
Çok akıllı, inanılmaz iyi niyetli,
benim de çok yakın arkadaşlarımdan
ama Murat'ın ufak bir sıkıntısı vardı.
İngilizce seviyesi çok iyi değildi.
Ama bize lokal seviyede çok yardımcı
olduğu için sen de bizle gel dedik.
Proje başladı, aktiviteler başladı
ve bir akşam dediler ki
kültürlerarası yemek yapalım dediler.
Hollanda gubu, Almanya
grubu, Bulgar, Türkler.
Herkes kendi yemeklerini yaptılar.
Yemek yapmayı bilenler yaptı,
biz de biraz yardımcı olduk
ve en sonunda masalar hazırlandı.
Almanlar kendi yemekleriyle,
Hollandalılar, biz; biz zaten döktürmüşüz.
Bulgarlar bize biraz daha yakın
ve sunumlar başladı. Almanlar dedi ki:
Bu Sauerkraut, bu bu bölgeden
bunu babaannem çok yapardı.
Sonra Hollandalılar geldi anlattı.
Bulgarlar ve biz anlattık.
Bu arada Bulgar gruptan bir çocuk
gün içerisinde şehri gezmiş.
Aktiviteye katılmamış.
Yapmaması gereken bir şey.
Sonradan geldi, sunumları da kaçırdı.
Vicdani rahatsızlığından ötürü mü yoksa
işgüzarlığından ötürü mü bilmiyorum ama
zaten sunumu yapılmış yemekleri tek tek
gidip masalara bu ne diye sormaya başladı.
İlk Alman masasına gitti. Masaya baktı,
eller arkada böyle müfettiş gibi
'What is this?' yaptı.
Almanlar son derece ciddi bir şekilde bu
bu yemek, bu bu yörenin tekrar anlattılar.
Sonra Hollanda masasına gittiler,
'What is this?' dedi.
Yine aynı ciddiyetle anlattılar. Sonra
bizim masaya gitme hatasını yaptı bu çocuk
burada da biz yokuz artık
biz diğer yemekleri yiyoruz.
Murat orada kebapları
götürüyor tabii.
Çocuk o masaya gidip Murat'a
bir soru sorma gafletinde bulundu
ve şöyle bir an yaşadık biz.
Masa burada, çocuk böyle gidiyor.
Ben görüyorum artık bir
kolizyon(çarpışma) olacak ve
orada bir şeyler olacak.
Hızlı olarak şöyle oldu.
Çocuk baktı, masaya baktı.
Muhattap bulamadı. Murat'ı gördü.
'What is this?' dedi
O Nasrettin hoca fıkralarında olur ya.
Murat durur mu, cevabı yapıştırmış diye.
Murat'ın cevabı şu:
'This is a pencil' ve devam etti.
Biz buna saatlerce güldük.
Ağlaya ağlaya güldük.
Yabancılar bunu anlamadı tabii.
Neden gülüyorsunuz siz dedi.
Onlara anlatamıyoruz tabii
biz çocukken bu cümleleri öğrenirdik;
sonra Murat bunu yaptı.
Bu ve bunun gibi binlerce hikâye
bana seyahat aşkını aşıladı.
Hiçbir zaman unutamadığım,
beni duygulandıran, beni güldüren
beni mutlu eden binlerce hikâye.
Ama benim seyahat aşkım,
babam sayesinde başladı.
Eğitmen işini yapan babam Türkiye'nin
dört bir yanına eğitimlere gidiyordu.
Sivas'a, Zonguldak'a, Diyarbakır'a
Antep'e ve her gittiği yerden
bir şey getiriyordu. Bir de şu
havayollarında uçaktan aldığı
kolonyalı mendili getirirdi hep ben de
onları hep biriktirirdim.
Koleksiyonum olurdu çünkü o kolonyalı
mendiller benim için seyahat demekti.
O kolonyalı mendiller benim
için tecrübe demekti.
için keşif demekti.
Ben de dedim ki, ben de
babam gibi gezeceğim
Sağolsunlar çocukken beni bi'
Fransa'ya götürdüler.
bi' İngiltere'ye götürdüler.
Bi' de Amerika'ya gittik.
O konuda şanslıydık.
Tabii burada, böyle bir şey yaptılar.
Seyahat virüsü benim kanıma bulaştı
bir defa.
İlk başta üniversitede konferanslara
giderek; babamın, annemin desteğiyle
Çanakkale 18 Mart Üniversitesinde okudum
ben onların verdikleri harcırahlarla
Avrupa'yı gezebildim. Orta hâlli bir
ailenin çocuğu olarak.
İlk seyahatim Hollanda'yaydı.
15 gün 30-40 yabancının olduğu bir
etkinliğe gittim. Yaz okuluna.
Ve hayatımın en güzel 15 gününü geçirdim.
15 günün sonunda
isimlerimize zarflar vardı.
Benim de ismimdeki zarfa,
mesajları atıyorlardı.
Bir arkadaşım hiç unutmuyorum,
şu mesajı atmıştı bana.
Okudum ve hâlen buradadır o mesaj.
Dedi ki, 'Perçin, 15 güne neler
sığdırabileceğini artık gördün' dedi.
Gerçekten öyleydi. Senelerde
yaşayamayacağım şeyleri ben
15 güne sığdırmıştım ve dedim ki
ben seyahat etmeliyim.
Avrupa'yı gezdim. Sonra Belçika'ya
taşındım üniversiteden sonra.
Daha da kolaylaştı seyahat çünkü burada
Tekirdağ diye bir tabela gördüğünüzde
Belçika'da Fransa diye
bir tabela görüyordunuz.
Dedim ki, Avrupa çok ufak.
Sonra dedim ki, bundan
daha büyüğü de olmalı.
(Güney) Kore'ye bir konferansa gittim.
14 saat uçaktan sonra
indim. 1 saat dinlendim.
Dediler ki, sabah görüşürüz.
Resepsiyona gittim, dedim
en yakın merkez nerede?
O merkeze üç, dört saat boyunca yürüdüm.
Yol bilmeden, iz bilmeden,
haritaya bakmadan.
Işıkları seyrederek, insanlara bakarak.
Sarılan çiftlere bakarak.
Binalara bakarak.
Her şey farklıydı ve hayatımın
en güzel saatlerinden biri de oydu aslında
Dedim ki, Dünya da çok ufakmış aslında.
Sonra Hindistan'a gittim.
Gönüllü öğretmenlik yaptım
Sonra Rusya'da sırt çantamı aldım, aynen
böyle, Tayland'a kadar 9000 km gittim.
3 ay boyunca hatta daha fazla gidecektim.
O zamanki kız arkadaşım dedi ki:
'Daha fazla gezersen
ben senden ayrılırım' dedi.
Ben de dedim ki: 'He, ben döneyim o zaman'
Sonra biraz da ülkemi keşfedeyim dedim.
Karadeniz'e gittim. O harika doğayı gördüm
Egeye gittim o güzel insanlarıyla tanıştım
Akdeniz'e gittim. O sıcacık iklimi tattım.
Güneydoğu Anadolu'ya gittim.
Hayatımda görmediğim kadar samimi ve
içten insanlar gördüm.
Dedim ki, benim ülkem de güzelmiş.
Sonra nedenimi buldum ben. Dedim ki:
Seyahat benle evren arasındaki bağı
kuvvetlendiren bir şey.
Ve ben bu yüzden gezmeliyim.
Artık nedenim çok kuvvetliydi.
Ve beni hiç bir şey tutamazdı.
Ve şunu kendime amaç edindim. Ömrüm
yettiğince Dünya'nın her ülkesine
bu Kuzey Kore olsun, Afganistan olsun,
Grönland olsun
Venezuella olsun hiç fark etmez.
Hepsine tek tek gidecektim.
Ve şu ana kadar 60 ülkeye
gidebildim, 30 yaşında
ve dediğim gibi ömrüm yettiğince hepsine
gideceğim çünkü o kadar güzel hikâyeler
yaşadım ki, ben bu hikâyelere
devam etmek istiyorum.
Mesela, çocukken ilk gittiğim Fransa'da
Disneyland'ı kocaman gözlerle "Aaa, burası
çok büyükmüş" dedikten sonra.
25 yaşında tekrar gidip
oradaki aşık olduğum kızla anılarımı
tekrar canlandırmak gibi.
Ya da Moldova'da taksiye bindiğimde
birinin camı tık tık tık tıkladığında
korkup açtığımda; adamın: "ya bugün burada
milli tatil, lütfen taksiyi
beraber paylaşabilir miyiz aynı yöne
gideceksek?" diye sorması gibi
ve bindiğinde benim 2010'daki
Eurovision'da 50 kere şarkısını dinlediğim
Moldova grubunun saksafoncusu
olduğunu keşfetmem gibi adamın
ve sonra onula McDonald's'da
yemek yememiz gibi...
2017'de tekrar çıktılar bu arada.
Ya da Viyana'da arkadaşıma gittiğimde seni
babaannemle tanıştırayım dediğinde
o kadının hikâyesini dinlemek gibi.
Babası bir Nazi subayı olduğu için
yaşadığı acıları ve İsveç'e kaçan
kardeşinin; şu an hayatta olmayan
kardeşinin yaptığı bestelerle
hep beraber oturup dinlemek gibi.
(Güney) Kore'ye gittiğimde;
Kore hamamına gittiğimizde.
Bu temsili bir resim tabii,
orada resim çekmedim.
Bana kızmalarını;
bana neden kızıyorlar dediğimde
şortunu çıkarmalısın; biz Kore hamamında
anadan üryan giriyoruz dediklerinde
şaşırmam gibi...
Ve sonra bir babanın yanındaki çocuğun
benim kıllı göğsümü gördüğünde
çok daha fazla şaşırması gibi...
Yunanistan'a gittiğimde insanların
din ve dil dışında bize
ne kadar benzediğini anlamam gibi...
Bir taksiciye adres sorduğunuzda, aynı
bizimkiler gibi ellerini omzunuza koyup:
Kardeş bak, şuradan git
dediklerini anladığım gibi...
Ya da İspanya'ya gittiğinizde herhangi
bir kafeye arkadaşlarınızla girdiğinizde
Onlara ‘Camarero’ diye bağırdığınızda;
onların ise 'Que' diye sormalarını
ve bunun bir şarkı olduğunu
keşfettiğinizde 'Camarero'-'Que' diye
Karşılık aldığınızda; ritmine
uyan herhangi bir kelimeyi söyleyip
Mesela (İspanyolca kelimeler) dediğinizde
(İspanyolca kelimeler) dedikleri ve
50 kişi hep beraber
tanımadığınız kişiyle
(İspanyolca kelimeler) demeniz gibi.
Sonra dedim ki:
30 yaşına geldim, 60 ülke gördün.
Bunlardan neler öğren, bir otur,
bir yaz, bi' bak dedim kendi kendime
ve oturdum bir liste çıkardım.
Hakkaten hem kişisel hayatımda
hem de profesyonel hayatımda
bana inanılmaz destek olacak
ve yön gösterecek bir liste oluşturdum.
Mesela tecrübeye değer
vermek gibi öğrenimlerimde.
Malın olur, mülkün olur. Çok güzel
Bir günde kaybedebiliyorsun.
Sevdiklerinle olman, onlara
güvenmen çok güzel bir şey.
Hayatından çıkabiliyorlar;
isteyerek ya da istemeyerek.
Ama kendine zihnine ve kişiliğine değer
verdiğin zaman, ona yatırım yaptığın zaman
hayatta olduğun sürece hiç bir şey seni
aşağıya indiremiyor. İndirse de
Daha güçlü ayağa kalkıyorsun
ve seyahat bunu öğretiyor.
Öğrettiği dillerle, edindiğin
arkadaşlarınla, orada yönettiğin risklerle
ve hayal bile edemeyeceğin şeyler sana
geliyor; tıpkı benim burada bugün
TEDx sahnesinde konuşmam gibi.
Önyargıları yıkmayı öğretti
bana seyahat; birine
Aaa sen Türksün, aaa sen Kürtsün,
Aaa sen Çerkezsin, aaa sen Lazsın
Aaa sen homoseksüelsin, aa sen şusun değil
insan olduğuna değer vererek
önyargısız yaklaşmayı öğretti seyahat
bana çünkü bana öyle yaklaştı insanlar.
Mesela, Belçika'da yüksek lisans yaparken
resimdeki, yanımdaki Alman arkadaşımı ilk
gördüğümde, aa bu sünepe diye ona
yaklaştığımı sonra ben bu çocuğun dört dil
bilen süper zeki ve inanılmaz karakteri
olan bir çocuk olduğunu keşfetmem gibi.
Sonra dedim ki, ben insanları
yargılamamalıyım.Ben kimim ki yargılıyorum
Sadece insan olduğu için sevmeliyim.
Hatta bu çocuk bana, Belçika'da biz
bir barda bira içerken; ben çok uyanık
olduğum için bardağı beğenip eve götüreyim
bu bardağı dediğimde beni yolda elimde
bardakla görüp. Bırakın beni yargılamayı;
bana şu soruyu sorması gibi
çünkü kafasında böyle bir
konsept yoktu çocuğun
Perçin, sen evden kendi bardağını
mı getirmiştin de bardağı
geri götürüyorsun diye sorması gibi...
Çünkü öyle bir şey düşünemiyor çocuk.
Anda olmak gibi ya da...
Kız arkadaşınızla öpüşürken, annenize
sarılırken, çok güzel bir etkinlikte
konuşmacıyı dinlerken, değerli
arkadaşlarınızla otururken
geçmişi dert edip geleceği düşünmeyip
o an orada olmayı anlamak gibi...
O anın rüzgarını hissetmek, o anın sesini
duymak, o andaki insanların surat
ifadelerini algılamak gibi çünkü o anın
bir daha gelmeyeceğini anlamak gibi...
Çünkü seyahat ettiğinizde Azerbeycan'da
bir konferanstayken, bir hafta boyunca
o konferansa katılıp, size aşık olan kız
siz kumsalda otururken, ansızın yanınıza
gelip; size aşık olduğunu şöyle
belirtebiliyor size. Kulağınıza
yaklaşıyor ve diyor ki;
'Deniz kaçar, gel ey seher, gel ey seher'
Diyip aşkını ilan edebiliyor size ve siz o
anda başka bir yerde olmamak istiyorsunuz.
Bu temsili bir resim tabii,
o anın resmini çekmedim.
Teşekkür etmeyi öğrenmek gibi...
Hindistan'da öğretmenlik yaptığınızda,
panjurları açtığınızda içeriye
su girdiği için ders yapamadığınız,
panjurları kapadığınızda karanlık
olduğu için ders yapamadığınız gibi
ve o zaman Allah'ım verdiğin her şey için
teşekkür ederim demeniz gibi...
Bununla da yetinmeyip,
bana verilen şeylerle
insanlara nasıl katkıda bulunabilirim
diye düşünmeniz gibi aslında...
Ya da tevekkül gibi, değiştirebileceğiniz
şeyleri değiştirip, bundan derslerinizi
çıkarıp yolunuza devam edip,
değiştiremeyeceğiniz şeyleri de kabullenip
bundan dersinizi çıkarıp yolunuza
devam etmek gibi...
Çünkü Kamboçya'da bir otobüs
bozulduğunda yolun ortasında kaldığınızda
ya o an bir opsiyonunuz varsa onu kullanıp
yolunuza devam ediyorsunuz bir opsiyonunuz
yoksa da, en yakın kahveye gidip
2-3 saat kahvenizi içip, çayınızı içip
oradaki insanlarla tanışıp, bir sonraki
planınızı yapıyorsunuz.
Başka bir yolunuz yok.
Ya da sevmek gibi...
Bu dünyada maalesef birçok insanın
korkuyla insanlara yaklaştığını
yalnızlık korkusu, sevilmeme korkusu,
kaybetme korkusuyla çok korkunç şeyler
yaptığını ama birçok insanın da
sevmeyi bildiğini sevmeyi öğrendiğini
ve ne olursa olsun size sevgiyle
yaklaşabildiğini anlamak gibi...
İnsanları yargılamadan kendinizi
kurban durumuna düşürmeden...
Mardin'e gittiğinizde ara sokaklarda
çocuklarla tanıştığınızda onların sizin
kim olduğunuzu umursamaksızın,
size sevgiyle yaklaşıp size sarılmaları
abi bir resim çekelim mi demesi gibi...
Hatta abi sen nerelisin diye
sorduklarında İstanbulluyum dediğinizde
abi benim orada Ercan abim var kuzenim
selam söyle dediği gibi...
Sen de tanımıyorum kuzenini ama bir gün
görürsem selam söylerim dediğiniz gibi...
Çünkü siz kendinizi sevmezseniz,
etrafınızı da sevemezsiniz tıpkı
kendi içinizi değiştirmezseniz, etrafınızı
da değiştiremeyeceğinizi gibi...
Burada en güzel kısım ne biliyor musunuz?
Siz kadın, erkek, dul, bekar, hamile,
ikiz çocuğu olan, zengin, fakir, genç,
yaşlı farketmeksizin seyahatin sizin için
önemini anladığınızda nedeninizi
gördüğünüzde ve bunu içselleştirdiğinizde
o zaman kimse sizi tutamaz çünkü ben tüm
bu kategorilerde gezen ve bir şeyler
öğrenen insanlar gördüm.
Benim nedenim, dediğim gibi evrenle
aramdaki bağı kuvvetlendirmek
ve böylece, kendime mahalleme, topluluğuma
ülkeme, dünyama daha faydalı insan
olabilmek çünkü bence seyahat bunun
yollarından biri
ve en önemlisi de artık bu dünyada olmayan
ama farklı bir dünyada
yaşayan babam ve annemin
her gezdiğimde benim kalbimde, benim
beynimde, benim ruhumda
benimle tecrübe etmesini,
benimle sevmesini
benimle aşık olmasını,
benimle öğrenmesini keşfettiğim gibi...
Ben de o zaman gözlerimi
kapıyorum ve diyorum ki:
Seni seviyorum, beni affet.
Özür dilerim, teşekkür ederim.
Teşekkür ederim.